[Music]
China is currently experiencing the
largest mass migration ever witnessed in
human history over the past 30 years
China's urban population has grown by
over half a billion people thanks
largely to a vast exodus of peasants
from the countryside and the Chinese
government is trying to speed this
influx through an official urbanisation
Drive so as to bolster the country's
declining economic growth rate in theory
urbanization makes a lot of economic
sense urban workers tend to be more
productive but in China the domestic
migration comes with a big political
catch the catch known as the Hoopoe
system an identification and
registration program utilized for social
control by the Ministry of Public
Security in practice most peasants who
move to urban areas for better jobs keep
their rural eco meaning they cannot
obtain urban social services cantering
their children along through and less
than comparably skilled urban
counterparts and face further
discrimination to sounds almost like a
parth I dare a South Africa in such a
repressive arrangement really lasts
forever what do you think is China's
most pressing population problem let us
know in our poll also let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI